petra is a popular instructor and
excellent developer in this course he
teaches how to build a live streaming
flutter app using agora thanks to agora
for providing a grant that made this
course possible hello everyone my name
is titus petra i am a youtuber a google
developer expert for flutter and dart
and also a developer evangelist at
aguero and this course will be covering
a live streaming application where you
can have multiple live stream feeds from
multiple people coming into a director
application the director has control of
whether they're muted whether their
videos on and whether they're on the
stage or the lobby and then for those
people that are in the stage their video
will get transcoded together and sent
out to any streaming platform that you
want i'd say this course is an
intermediate level course so if you're
completely new or flutter i recommend
taking a look at some of the other free
code cam courses i know they have some
great ones for beginners and if you're
completely new to agora i'll leave a
couple of resources in the description
so you can see how to implement simple
video calling features with it i will
also be using veripod for state
management i'll be explaining a little
bit about what state management is and
how we're going to use it here but if
you want to dive a little bit deeper
i'll leave some resources in the
description too and lastly i'd like to
thank free code camp for giving me this
opportunity and let's get into the
course
got a little cold in here i had to put
on a sweatshirt but like i said this app
is a little bit more complicated so i
wanted to break it down to visually
we're going to start off with a home
screen on the home screen we're going to
have to enter two fields one is the name
of the room the other one is your name
and there's gonna be two buttons because
technically we're gonna have basically
two apps within one app we're going to
have a participant view but we're also
going to have a director view so the
first view is going to be the
participant view now this view should
look like any other normal video call
you can have you'll have an end call
button a mute button and a switch camera
button within the participant view
you're basically saying you're going to
be a participant within the video call
that the director controls so what you
should see is basically what's going to
be going out to the public the people
that are going to be going out to the
live stream platforms they're going to
be the people that are on the stage i'll
explain the stage in this next part so
this is the basics of the director
layout so the director basically
controls how the whole video calls going
and who actually gets pushed out to the
live stream and who doesn't so you'll
have first the lobby here so when you
first join as a participant you'll be
put into the lobby then the director
will have the ability to bring you into
the stage and then you'll be basically
live
and the director will also have the
ability to bring you back to the lobby
if you misbehave or something like that
at the top here we'll put basically what
streaming platforms you want to go to so
let's say youtube and twitch if you have
entered that at the bottom we'll have a
menu
for stuff like end call and start and
stop live stream so as you can see
there's a lot of stuff going on in this
director application that's where state
management comes in not to be perfectly
clear you don't need state management
here you could definitely make this app
work without it but in my opinion adding
some sort of state management solution
kind of cleans up the code a little bit
and makes it easier to work with so what
is state management so if we take a look
at this application within the director
part of it we have a lot of different
states
so we have stuff like who are the people
on the stage
people in the lobby what platforms we're
streaming to whether the live stream is
live or not and things like that so
depending on how big your application is
and how much of these state objects
you're going to be using on different
pages you might want to split it up into
multiple
state objects so you could have
something like a state object for people
on the stage a state object for people
in the lobby a state object for
what type of platforms you want to go to
and a state object for whether the
stream is started or not but for this
we're going to keep things simple we're
just going to have one state object for
everything directly related so something
like a director
state now within here we'll have active
users lobby users
is live variable to tell us if we're
live or not and which destinations we
want to stream to so that is the state
that we're going to be managing for this
application and the whole director page
so this whole page
will be reactive to whenever this state
changes
so anytime you update this
the our director screen will react and
update the ui to match
whatever needs to match and of course
when we click button so let's say
there's a plus button to add a
destination here whenever we click it
we'll go to a function that changes and
updates this destination which updates
the state which updates the screen and
thus we have a nice simple flow for how
things get updated within our
application hopefully that makes sense
and for the participant app since it's
simple enough there's not too many
things to manage we're not even going to
use any state management for that so why
do we choose the gore for this project
well first i work there so i'm a little
bit biased but also it makes building
something like this a little bit easier
than other competitors and also has a
very powerful backend so you know you'll
be getting quality and reliability and
all that stuff now the agora platform
will be taking care of all the video
feeds that are coming in and putting
them together sending them out to the
live streams but also using signaling
between the director and all the
participants whether they're muted or
whether they should be in the lobby or
the stage and stuff like that all right
enough explaining things let's show how
this is actually built so we're going to
start off with the old flutter create
command
i'm going to call this app streamer
then we could jump into the directory
and open it in vs code and here we have
our basic flutter app and there we go
we're running the basic flutter demo
application now before moving forward we
want to add in all the dependencies that
we need so he said the main thing that's
going to be running on is agora if we go
to the package manager for dart we type
in agora we will see three agora plugins
now we're going to be using the agora
rtc engine and the agora rtm
but i want to show you what a gore ui
kit does too because it's really quick
and simple
so we have added a glower ui kit here so
so this is used if you want to set up a
simple video call application now the
plan is to expand this to allow all the
complex features too so technically what
we'll be building here should also be
possible with ui kit in the future as
well so that's why i want to show it to
you a little bit so in order to add ui
kit to your project you only really need
to add three lines of code we need to
create an agora client and we can pass
in agora connection data and enable
permissions so we're gonna need two
permissions for a video call we're gonna
need a camera permission and a
microphone permission now the sigour
connection data is a class that we need
to add and you'll see you'll need app id
and channel name so what the heck is
that well if you go to
dot console.agora.io you'll see a screen
like this now i have a list of all your
projects you can create a new project
but for us we're just going to be using
this project that i already have
but you should see something very
similar and when you create it you might
see a screen like this and you'll have a
thing called app id right here
so this is basically creating an agora
app for you and you'll be able to use
agora services and you'll have 10 000
free minutes of these services every
single month so we're going to be
copying this app id and bringing it into
our code now in order to not be showing
you my app id this whole time i'm going
to have a new file and i'm going to call
it app id
and here i'll define const
app id equals
and then insert
app
id here
name this file with lowercase
underscores that's fine but then you're
going to want to insert your app id here
but i'm going to put in my number so
there we go mine's in there
and now we can type in app id here and
it will import our app id file and we
can use that constant variable here for
our channel we're just going to call it
test for now then we want to initialize
that client
and then we're done so all the gore side
is this initialized and we will just
want to display
a stack of widgets one of them is going
to be the agora video viewer which will
show you the actual video we pass in the
client
and then we have agora
video buttons so we could have an end
call button
and stuff like that and that's a full
video call application before i can
demonstrate though there are some
permissions we need to add so on the
android level build.gradle we need to
add this at the end of the repositories
so we can add that in here then add the
device permissions which we already did
android manifest file add this required
device permission to the file so there
we go now this video call should be
working and we should be able to launch
it and showcase it
all right there was apparently a bug
that took a little while to figure out
but
i there was either a new android version
or a new permissions handler version
that was released so you want to make
sure you set your target sdk version and
your compile sdk version both to be 31.
by default in flutter projects as 30 and
something doesn't like that with
permissions so
with 31 everything works and you see an
app like this so it'll ask for your
permissions
let's give it permissions to do all that
and this little image is something we'll
see throughout the video and this is the
little fake camera emulator from android
let me join another device just to prove
to you that this works and i forgot
since mine is an ios device we're going
to have to add these two things to the
info.plist file
so ios runner info.plist
and add these two keys in here
now save that
and
this time hopefully it will work
and there we go here i am
so that was the gore ui kit and while
you can do a lot of things with the gore
ui kit you can actually do a lot of
customizations there's a couple small
things you can't do right now that we're
working on adding in so we're going to
need to use the core api called agora
rtc engine
so the agora rtc engine handles all the
video and audio related stuff
but then when you also need to add agora
rtm which is real-time messaging
rtc stands for real-time communication
rtm stands for real-time messaging and
you can imagine the messaging is to send
signals between the people so we can
have control of everybody within the
call so those are going to be the
packages driving the core agora logic
then we're going to need to add river
pod we're going to use flutter river pod
that's for the state management
and then we're going to add a couple
little small things like shared
preferences we're going to need this
because we're going to have to have a
uid of a person that we're going to
generate randomly and we're going to
store it so we don't have to create a
new one every single session there's
other ways to get uids for example from
firebase and all that stuff but we're
going to do a simple route and share
preferences just makes it easier for you
to store things locally and then we're
going to have a couple neat little ui
packages one's going to be called
app pop-up menu just like it sounds it's
just a little pop-up menu then we have a
modal
bottom sheet
which is a nice little thing that comes
up from the bottom so you can add some
information in there
and then last one
circular menu
so really there's three main ones
driving the actual logic behind
everything that happens then share
preferences just to store things locally
easily and then three ui packages it's
ui elements that we could definitely
make ourselves but why not use the
things we have out there all right so
everything's set up and ready to go now
i have a way that i organize projects
it's similar to the mvu architecture
approach
and it's a nice way to keep things
organized within your app so that you
can keep building up and building up on
it so i have a folder called controllers
that's not a folder
i have a folder called models
pages
utils
and sometimes they even have a folder
for widgets but in this case we're not
going to need them so the app id goes
within the utils and we don't need to
look at that anymore so utils as you
could see is utilities stuff they use
throughout the app but it's not really a
feature or anything like that so for
example i put my colors in here
different colors that i have for the app
and i can't even think of many other
examples of things i put in here but
it's nice to keep those organized
then pages like it sounds is a different
pages of the application
models are the data objects so the
different types of data that you hold
within the application and then
controllers are the main things that
drive the whole application so if you
remember how we're using riverpod for
state management and then we have that
director state that we talked about so
that director state is going to be
within the controller so we can actually
add the files so we can envision it even
better so we'll have a director
controller
and here we'll have the director model
which is the big object that we're going
to be using
to control the whole application
then we'll have a simple stream.dart
this is going to have the information
for where we're streaming to
and the user.dart for all the people
that are going to be within the call and
any data that we need to hold for them
then pages there's only three pages here
we will have the home page we'll have
the director page
and then we'll have the participant page
okay so everything's set up we're ready
to start adding some code in here so we
can remove this home page class remove
all this
and we'll just call it home
we can leave all that as is remove the
title we don't really need that now
since we're using riverpod we want to
wrap this whole material app with a
provider scope so there we go this
provider scope basically a widget that
stores state so we're storing state for
the whole application so wrapping it
around this whole material app now this
home we see we have a problem but we'll
add a stateful widget here called home
now we can import that
and i think we can even make it custom
there we go
so we're pretty much done with this
whole main page we won't be touching it
much more now the home screen if we take
a look at our design we want the home
screen to look something like this
whether you're a participant or a
director it's actually going to be a
little bit different because one we're
going to need a username and then we
also need a channel name so instead of
adding channel name here we're also
going to put it in the first screen so
we need channel name username and then
two buttons
so first we need to create a scaffold
and then in the body we're gonna have a
center widget
in which
we'll have a column
within this column let's center
everything
and the children will be two text fields
and two buttons so the first text button
will
take us to participant
and the second text button will
take us to
director
and actually let's go and set both of
those up so for the child of the
participant we're going to have a row
with the word participant and the little
icon
the icon is going to be a live tv
because you're going to be pretty much
joining a live broadcast
and the child for the director will be
the word director and a little cut thing
so
you know you know that you're directing
something or you're in charge of
something
so let's set up our participants screens
as well
so we have a stateful widget called
participant and then in here we will
just do a simple scaffold
with a body
center
text
participant
and let's just copy the same thing to
director just to make sure everything
works
by the way you can click ctrl d to do
what i did here
and i just change all the wording to
director
now in order to get to that next page we
need to do navigator dot push and then
send our page route for the specific
widget that we want to push on so we
want to push the participant widget here
and then do the same thing
for the director except here we will
push the director page
all right so now we can actually run
this to make sure at least the
navigation within the app works
all right we ran into a little bug that
didn't let us run
so in this maven link
i had www.jetpack.io
if you have this or i accidentally led
you to have this make sure you remove
that
and then your coach should run
so we have an app that looks like this
and i think if we click into it we'll be
taken to the director screen
and now if we click participant we'll be
taken to the participant screen
so our whole flow for the application is
working now we just need to make this
look a little bit nicer
so let's create another folder in here
we'll call it assets
this assets folder will we will put all
our images and things like that
so let's put it out into the main
directory
and there's the assets
and here we'll have the streamer you
can't really see it because it's a black
background
but you just gotta trust me that this is
the this is the right logo
now to actually to actually add it into
our app we have to go to the
pubspec.yaml
and here they have a commented out
section that shows you how to add assets
but we're just gonna
add ours in
and it's in the directory called assets
so now it's ready to use so at the very
top we'll have image dot asset
and our path is assets slash streamer
dot png it's add a little space between
this and the next section
we'll give it a height of only five
add some text like multi
streaming with
friends
and these can be constants because they
are not going to change
and another size box to give some space
in between
the titles and the text fields
we'll have a height of 40 here and then
for the text fields we'll do something a
little more special
so first things first we need some
controllers up here so i have a channel
name controller and a username
controller to format this to look a
little nicer we're going to wrap it in a
container
and we're going to give it a specific
width of media query
width so this is the width of our screen
and we're going to multiply it by 8.85
so it's going to take up 85 percent of
the screen
this will make it more responsive for
the different apps that we have
now within that text field we'll have a
controller this will be the
username
and then some decoration
and this decoration is just going to
give it a nice little border
and have the text username in there so
nothing too special
now we want to size box again
of height 8 here for example
and i'll hit copy paste the same thing
here you notice it converted to a size
box because we're not really
using much else within here we're not
using many of the container things so
size box works here as well
and here we'll have the channel name and
change this to channel name
all right let's run that
so there we go it looks looks pretty
nice now
now there's one more thing we didn't do
is we need to add properties that we
pass in here so we have a channel name
and username but we need to actually
pass it into these specific widgets so
this is the participant screen we're
going to need the channel and the
username here and then for the director
screen we actually don't even need the
username we only need the channel name
the director won't actually be within
the call so we don't need to see his
username anywhere
but we run into issues here because
we're not passing the specific things we
need
just
simple to fix channel name we take the
controller we have
and we get the text from it same thing
with username we take the user
controller
and take the text from it
so this is taking
the controller that we have set up for
each of the text fields
so when you're typing there's a nice
little
thing in the background that has all the
text for it for you and we're retrieving
that text value from it
and then we should have one more problem
at the director
where we do something very similar
channel name
we take the channel name controller and
retrieve the text so now each of these
screens should have the correct values
that we need and we should be good to go
all right so for our next part we're
going to start implementing the
participant side of things the
participant is
going to be a lot simpler than director
so hopefully it'll be a good transition
from implementing something a little bit
simpler and then we'll step it up
another level
by adding it into the director the
participant still has a lot of things
that we need to take care of and since
this is a more complicated app there's
going to be a lot of functions that the
participant has to
execute on as well but but we'll take it
slow and hopefully by the end you'll
have a good understanding of
how all these stuff works together so
the biggest thing we'll be emphasizing
here is how agora rtm and agora rtc work
together so if you remember rtm is
real-time messaging so it's signaling
it's how we'll be able to communicate
information between people so send like
mute requests and all that type of stuff
and then agora rtc will be the actual
video call happening
so on the participant side of things we
will need
rtc
engine
which is going to be handling the actual
video call
and then for rtm we will have
a client and then we also have a
channel so within the agora rtc engine
or agora rtc package this
client and channel logic is within this
rtc engine thing just made it a little
simpler to use so you could add video
call a little bit easier so the gora rtm
everything is broken down to
exactly how things work behind the
scenes so as i said the agora rtc engine
will be the actual video call
the agora rtm client is you logging into
agora rtm itself
and then agora rtm channel is joining
that channel actually let's go and
initialize this and you'll see exactly
what i mean
so here we're creating the actual engine
and then if we go to join
channel you'll see you have to give a
token which will give us no
but then we need to pass in a channel
name so this channel that you pass in
here does the actual initialization
very similar to how agora rtm does this
initialization for this channel we're
actually not going to be doing this yet
but i just wanted to show it to you so
we created the instance of our engine
now let's do the same thing with our
client and for both of these you notice
we pass in our app id that we created
for our gore so now we have a connection
with the engine and the client to our
agora project so by default agora rtc
starts with only audio so we want to
make sure we enable video so we can
actually see the video streams and then
set this person's channel profile to
live broadcasting there's three types of
channel profiles there's live
broadcasting a normal video call and a
gaming one so we're gonna be using the
live broadcasting
and then you can either be a broadcaster
or an audience member
they will be a broadcaster in this case
all right so the basics are initialized
and we're ready to move forward with it
the next thing we want to set is our
event handlers
so these event handlers get triggered
whenever
some sort of event happens within our
application
and there's a lot of them we're going to
be implementing a lot more of them but
for now
let's just
do one to showcase how it works
so we have join channel success you can
hover over this and it occurs when the
local user joins the specified channel
so we'll do here we'll actually have a
list of
integers
with the users that are within this call
now whenever this person joins we'll
have users dot
add
and we'll add their uid to this list of
users
i actually want to set state so we can
update the ui with this specific user
shown
this logic isn't how it's going to end
with because we don't want to just
display the current user that join want
to display any of the active people
within the
stage of the director application
but we'll handle that a little bit later
so okay here we set up the callbacks
for the rtc engine
now if you remember we have an rtc
engine and then we have rtm client and
rtm channel so those have callbacks as
well
so the rtm client is your connection to
the actual agora rtm thing so this is
like a personal connection to the agora
system
an rtm channel is the channel that you
join so this is like everybody in the
channel will be on the same channel but
you will be the only one on that
specific client hello editor tatus here
so i messed up my wording a little bit
there you won't be the only one on the
client but you will have an individual
connection to the client so this client
has callbacks like on message received
and this callback has a message and a
peer id so we go to the definition of
this so this callback occurs when the
local users receives a peer-to-peer
message so when you get a specific
message from a separate user to you
directly
this callback will execute and we'll
just print out private message from this
user with the message of this
so i don't think we'll actually be
needing to use this callback but i
thought we would include it because i
think it helps you understand what a
client and what a channel is but there's
one that we will definitely be using
it's on connection
state changed so this one will give us
two variables will give us the current
state and the reason so the reason is
why this connection state changed and
the state gives you what's the current
state
and you notice these are integers and we
can figure out what those integers mean
by going to developers on agora the io
go to documentation
in documentation go to api reference i'm
working with the real-time messaging and
currently there's no documentation for
the flutter sdk for this but from what i
know it's coming soon but it has the
same exact things as the android sdk
so we can get status and error codes and
we go to connection state and then
there's connection change reasons so
connection state we have connection
state aborted is equal to five so if
our state is equal to five
which means this connection state was
aborted we want to leave the channel
want to log out the client and we also
want to destroy the client
we could even add a print saying
logged out
so whenever our connection state is
aborted we want to just basically clear
out everything that we had going on now
we can even go to connection change
reasons we could see these numbers and
and we can figure out if we want to do
something specific for whatever reason
occurred we can do that but we're just
going to keep it simple for this example
okay so those were the callbacks for the
rtm client now the last one is the
callbacks for the rtm channel so these
are channel wide messages
this is what we're actually going to be
using to mute people and all that stuff
because we want to send a message to
every art everybody in the channel and
then the person within that channel
checks if they're supposed to mute
themselves and then they will go ahead
and mute if their uid is passed to this
channel message so first we're going to
use a simple example of member join so
you can see these printouts happen
whenever someone joins the channel let's
also have one for member left just so we
could have all this information and the
last and most important one will be
will be called on message received where
we'll get a message from the channel and
it'll tell us which member actually sent
this channel message so you notice these
callbacks are named exactly the same so
we have on message received here and our
message received here but remember this
is for the client
which means you're sending a specific
private message
and this is a channel wide message so
this is like a public message to
everybody within the channel
and again the documentation even says
occurs when receiving a channel message
we're going to
implement this later but for now we can
add another print statement here that
just tells us the public message
alright so there we go i know this might
seem a little complicated but once you
actually understand what's going on here
hopefully it's not too bad
so the last thing we have the callbacks
declared we have everything initialized
there's only one thing left to do and is
to actually join all these channels so
first things first we actually need to
log in with the client to agora and
here's where we run into the next
problem so i need to give a user id to
this client now there is a way around
this where you don't have to use a user
id but for this application we actually
need to because we're going to be using
rtc
and rtm and they need to have matching
user ids technically the user ids don't
have to match but you have to be able to
connect an rtm id and an rtc id since
we're going to be using these uids to
control all the users we need to figure
out a method to create these ids and to
do that we're actually going to pass in
a uid as well here and then down here we
could do widget.uid
and it actually needs to be a string
but we pass it in as an integer for a
specific reason that you'll see real
soon so then we create our channel and
you remember we passed in at the top the
channel name from that text field that
we got and i do that by client
create channel
and we get the channel name from the
text we passed it
but you'll probably notice something
here
we're creating the channel but we're
assigning callbacks on the channel here
that doesn't really make sense so we
want to move
this above the channel callbacks
to be honest we could probably move it
all the way up here just keep all the
callbacks together but but this works
just fine too so next step is take that
channel and we want to join so we have
the rtm part completely figured out we
logged in the client we created the
channel and we joined the channel now
for the rtc we have a very similar
approach
we have the rtc engine
but all we have to do here is just join
channel and it does all of this stuff
for us
and actually define the engine as a late
variable so
we don't need a question mark here by
the way if i went over that too fast
this late variable is with flutter 2.0
it means we're going to initialize this
before we use it and we know that for
for a fact because we're doing it
in a knit state we're initializing it up
here and we'll be using it down here so
it will for sure be initialized
again here we're not going to be using a
token
channel name will be the same channel
name optional info will put no
and optional uid we actually need it now
because we wanted to have a matching uid
to our rtm client so that's why we need
that uid okay so the initialization
everything should be done here obviously
ui isn't built yet but i think that's a
less complicated part so i wanted to get
this out of the way
now you know one thing we're missing is
this uid so let's go back to the home
and figure out a good way to do this so
we're going to implement the uid here
just to keep things a little
less cluttered and we're going to do
that in a very simple way
if this is a real application i'm not
sure if this is the best way to do it
it'd probably want to have some sort of
authentication service like firebase or
something like that to give you a uid
that you can keep track within a
database but we're going to create
something simple so during the
initialization we're going to get user
uid and if you remember we added a
package called
shared preferences
so this shared preferences just store
something locally
so the first time we run this we'll
generate a uid and then we'll just store
it locally and reuse that same uid that
we stored locally for any future video
calls so we have a function called get
user id and then we need to import
shared preferences so this get instance
loads and parses the preferences from
this app from the disk so all we have to
do is try to retrieve that local uid and
we'll have two scenarios we'll either
retrieve an actual stored uid
so that means we didn't get a null value
back
in which case we will
set our uid
right here to the stored uid or we
haven't created one yet and then we will
create it but this should only happen
once
now i won't type this whole algorithm
out but let me explain it so we get the
current date and time in milliseconds
since
how do you pronounce it i don't know but
it should give this exact time and any
time further in the future won't be the
same number so this number is a little
too long we need to have nine digits
for aguero to work so we take three
digits from the front which are the
numbers least likely to change and we
set those nine digits to the uid once
again that should only happen once and
then we should be good
so now we can pass the uid
to this participant
and finally the back end of our
participant side of things should be
done
now time to set up the front end alright
so we have the uid in here now the only
things that's left is actually updating
the ui actually there's a couple more
things left we have to
add some more
handlers here so for this we're gonna
have to do a little bit of logic here to
send the users the current user's
information
and uh when this person leaves we want
to clear all the users that we're seeing
too then also on message received this
will be a big part of the application so
we'll have to implement this
but for now let's just focus on the ui
get this looking right and then we will
be able to see our video call with just
this current user we can actually add
this leave channel handler in here so
whenever we
click end call or leave the channel we
clear all the users in there too and now
we can move this to do inside join
channel success and rename it to
add join channel logic
all right now let's move on to the ui so
we're gonna have a scaffold with a
center and then a stack of widgets now
the two widgets we'll have here is a
broadcast view and a toolbar so
broadcast view will be the actual video
feed we see and then layering on top of
it we'll have a little toolbar so we can
end the call and things like that so for
the broadcast view we'll have we'll have
a child of expanded
because we wanted to fill up the whole
screen
and then in here we will have a
an rtc local view and a surface view of
that local view but we need to import
that
we can do that right under the rtc
engine so keep the remote view in here
because we'll need it let's ignore the
prefix because i don't know i think it
looks a little bit nicer this way you
can of course follow the recommended
uh library prefix if you want but
we'll keep it like this for now
so and this takes our local agora view
and uh makes makes a view out of it
pretty much and apparently we don't even
need the container now for the toolbar i
feel like it's easier just to show it
all to you at the end instead of typing
it all out piece by piece
so we will have four buttons you'll see
a lot of errors right now because we
haven't implemented anything else
because i want to take it step by step
but we'll have four buttons each one of
them will do something simple so this
one will toggle your mute this one on
the call this one will disable your
video and then this one will switch your
camera
so each one of them has a function that
needs to execute and some of them will
need to hold a state actually so for
this one this button
it will look different depending if
you're currently muted or if you're not
muted same thing with the video disabled
so let's add those two states in here
and they both will start out as false so
you're not muted in this case and your
video is not disabled
and now to actually implement these
functions so first we have the on
toggle mute function
and this one we will just set the state
of that muted variable
to
not be muted
so that just changed the state locally
but now we need to change that state
within the actual video call
so we do engine dot mute
local audio stream
all right and we just set it to the
variable whether it's mute or not so
this will work for both cases whether we
mute or unmute we'll have something very
similar for on toggle video disabled
so this is for the button that turns our
video off and on
instead of mute local
audio stream we'll have mute local video
stream instead of a muted variable we
will have the video disabled variable so
almost exactly the same now to change
the camera is even easier
we have on switch
camera
so here we just call the engine and
everything will happen magically and
then finally the last one is
on call end
where we need to pass in the
the build context
and all we will do here is navigator
dot pop the context so we go back to the
previous screen now you might say
that doesn't really end the call that
just jumps you out of the screen
but we're gonna handle that in a pretty
nice way where we will add a dispose
method here so here we'll basically
clean up this whole video call and whole
rtm connection so that we have a fresh
slate whenever we go back into it
so first things first we want to leave
the channel for the video call
hash before we even do that we can clear
the users that we have
so clear this local variable of users
that we have
then we leave the video called channel
and we can destroy that
video call engine overall
then this is the rtm channel we can
leave
this channel as well then log out of the
client
this is the rtm client again
and then destroy the rtm client as well
so we take out care of the local state
we clear it we leave the channel and
destroy the video call
then we leave the rtm channel log out of
the client and destroy the client as
well and there we go so that's so that's
a nice way to handle all that end call
stuff because whenever you leave even if
you click the back button it will all
execute this end call logic so now we
should be actually able to run this
project and we will just see the
participant when you click the
participant button you'll be jumping in
a call with just yourself and we should
be able to see that person and since
we're running it on android the way it
works is they have like a emulator
camera which is just this little
pixelated image that they showed that
pretends like there's a camera there
well we ran into some issues
i tried to debug it a little bit so if
there's no users there i put out so that
shows no users on the screen
but if we try to join you'll see no
users at first then the user joins but
it's just a black screen
and when we leave we get an exception
called now this is because we missed a
very important step
we need another package called
permissions
handler
now with this package we'll be able to
ask for permissions to the camera and to
the microphone and you can't really have
a video call without permissions to that
so
that was what we were missing
so we're going to need two permissions
we need
permissions to the camera and we need
permission
to the microphone
and we need to request both those so
this is for the participant view and we
need to do the same thing for the
director view
actually i'm not sure if it's necessary
for the director but if you want to add
some functionality where you could bring
the director in as well
then you definitely need this
so now let's try to run it one more time
all right so username is tardis channel
name
we'll just call it titus again join as a
participant
we want to allow while using the app and
we want to allow while using this app so
we have no users at the beginning and
then we get this little android emulator
beautiful
now we should be able to mute the
simulator and you'll see the state
changes here
should be able to turn the camera off
and i think this doesn't work because it
is an emulator so there's no camera to
really turn off
and then we can switch camera
because that works so there's like the
back camera of the emulator
and then we can of course end the call
and it'll jump us back here
where everything gets destroyed so all
right that's the basic part of this
application hopefully you understood all
of it because it's only going to get
more complicated from here
or actually maybe it's not that much
more complicated but there's definitely
more pieces being added on to what we
already have here
so if you understood this participant
section this is i think the most
complicated part of this whole
course
the rest we're just going to be adding
on more stuff and making it all work
together nicely
okay so we got the participant mostly
handled now it's time to start with the
director app
we're going to come back to the
participants once we have the active
users and the people the stage users
all set up so that we can send them over
here and we display a different view
but now if you remember the director
application
so first we want to set up this director
state
this is going to be our state object
that the director part of the
application responds to whenever it
changes
and here we're going to have the active
users lobby users and then some other
little things but let's focus on these
active and lobby users first so this
active users is the one thing that we're
going to have to go back to the
participant side of things because we
want to not display just yourself but we
want to display the active users within
the actual call so to set up our state
we need to first create our director
model so this is the actual data piece
that we will be tracking
this is the specific state so this is
what types of data we're going to be
tracking and we'll have riverpod create
an instance of this data and use that
instance as our state object for the
application so we will have a class
called director
model now i realize my file naming isn't
the most consistent for these i just
have stream
and this one is director model but i
think it just made sense in my mind
because we have a page director we don't
want to have a model director and
controller director too so just to
differentiate this a little bit from the
director page so within the director
model we'll take a lot of things we had
in the participant side of things so
remember we needed an rtc engine we need
a client and we need our channel so we
will need those same exact things within
our director and for now we're just
going to have three more things in here
and that is a set of active users a set
of lobby users
and the local user so sets are pretty
much lists but you can only have one
occurrence within that list
so we're going to have a list of active
users our list of lab users and then the
local user which is the director and
here we could add a constructor so we
start off with an empty set of both
users and then we will add a copy with
method
so i do this using an extension called
dart data class generator
and then you do command period and you
can generate a copy with class so this
will allow you to change one thing
within the object and still have the
object so let's say
you added a lab user to the active user
you can copy with the instantiation of
this directory model that you have
except add a value to active user and
remove one from here and then you'll
have a new state object and before we go
forward we're actually going to change
something up a bit
so we're going to create a user class as
well so this user class will be called
agora user
and type of data we'll need here is a
uid
whether we are muted or not
whether the video is disabled
then a name for the user and the
background color that isn't too
important but it makes it look a little
bit nicer and i'll show you it later
again we need to create a constructor
for this
and same way as we did before we will
create a copy with class so if the user
goes from muted to unmuted we can change
this one variable and i have an object
with the new state now if we go back to
this director model we can actually
change
all these ants
to be agora users
so now we're ready to go one more thing
let's jump back in here so we have this
list of users we actually want it to be
a list of agora users
instead of just adding the uid we would
add an agora
user
with uid of uid
so we can keep things consistent
throughout the app all right next thing
is setting up the controller so this is
the workhorse of the application the
behind the scenes
state manager of the app we will be
using veripod like i said if you're not
familiar with veropod and state
notifiers specifically there's some
tutorials in the description that i
recommend to take a look but a state
notifier pretty much
holds this state
you can create functions in there that
update it
that we call those functions through
this directory screen so we call those
functions they update the state and
since it's a state notifier it will
notify whatever is listening to update
their current ui or whatever it is they
need to update because the state has
changed so that's the gist of a state
notifier so to use a state notifier you
need to create a state
notifier provider and we're going to go
one step further and auto dispose it so
it's auto dispose is basically whenever
we stop using this provider it will
dispose itself now within here we need
to give the type of what our state
notifier is going to be
and also what kind of state we'll be
managing so let's create our state
notifier we will have a director
controller
that extends state
notifier
and the state that we will be
managing is called the director model
now there's this reader that you will
see us passing in this reader is super
important so this allows you to read the
state of anything within the provider
scope
so any controllers that you have within
the provider scope and if you forgot
what the provider scope is
it's this thing that we surround the
whole application with so anything
within this has access to that read and
we're able to
access any other controller that's
within our app pretty much and during
the first demo i used another provider
somewhere else but in this case we might
not even use it so then here we need the
type of our state notifier so
we can just actually copy this
paste it here and the second thing we
need is the the type of the state we're
holding as director model then all we
need to do here is return this director
controller
with our reader all right there we go so
our state is all set up now we won't be
doing anything right now with the state
but just know it's there and we're ready
to work with it whenever we need to but
the thing we're going to do now is
actually set up our director screen
before any of this so do that we're
going to just take the scaffold
and wrap the whole thing with a consumer
widget
now this is consumer which has a
required argument of builder
and we will take this scaffold
and return it just like that
so what is this consumer so to explain
the consumer i went to the documentation
you can find all this through the
riverpod.dev website
and they're reading about providers then
there's a consumer over here and what
they say about consumers is that it can
be used to listen to providers inside a
staple widget or to rebuild as few
widgets as possible when the provider
updates
so this is the thing that actually
listens to the changes within our
provider in this case a state notifier
provider and updates our ui
to
look how we want it to look based on the
current state so in here you'll see this
watch thing we will use this watch
to look for the director controller
dot notifier
so let me type one more thing out and
explain these as well
so we have the director
model
which will be our director data
and we will watch
director controller
okay so what's going on here
so when we just watch our director
controller
directly we re we get this director
model
so we get the current data within that
provider
when we do director controller.notifier
we get the director controller
so we get this first part if you see if
we actually hover over the notifier
we get the director controller here so
this directory controller will give us
access to all the functions we need to
update our data
and this data will give us the current
data that we need
so just as a quick example we might do
director notifier
dot
mute user
or something like that
but then we'll have a text widget
that is tracking the director
data
active users
element at one
muted
so this is a long example but pretty
much we have one thing that will do the
actual muting of a specific user but
then when we get that user maybe user
one out of the active users we can read
its state from the director data okay so
now everything is ready to go and now
time to implement all these features so
we're going to start off with the
initialization and pretty much them
joining the call we want to initialize
this video call and actually join the
call from the director point of view
now i won't be showing the director
camera or anything but we still want him
to be within the call so he can control
everybody
so the two main functions are going to
be
joint call and then
also leave call
now the joint call is going to be a
little bit more complicated but the
leave call if we go back to the
participant screen is going to be the
same exact way as we did here
except this time we don't need to clear
any users because we're holding the
state within this director controller
you'll notice we get some errors here
because we don't have a private variable
of engine declared but remember we have
a state of director model and the
director model has engine client and
channels so we can do is we can create a
cursor like this and then just type out
state dot engine
and everything will work but we'll get
this because in this case the engine
isn't delayed variable it's actually
something that where we'll have to
make nullable due to the way
this whole directory controller is set
up
so that's how we're going to leave the
call now to initialize it we're going to
break it up a little bit we're going to
have a function called initialize
which will be a local function that does
all the initialization
remember the two main things is we need
an engine and a client
same thing we did here we went to
initialize agora
first things we did was create the
engine in the client
if you remember we created the channel a
little bit lower in the whole process
and that's exactly how we're going to do
it here
actually to make it easier on ourselves
we could literally just copy paste this
here
but we're declaring these here so
we need to set them rtc engine
to that and then import this as well
and also import agora rtm client
and import app id
so now we initialize it but they're
initialized into local variables we want
to actually add this to the state so
since this is a state notifier provider
every single time we want to update the
state we have to set it with a new state
variable so so we're not amending it use
a change notifier for that for a state
notifier we're sending a completely new
thing of course for this initial time
that obviously makes sense since we're
creating an object for the first time
but this is a key point to remember
about state notifier and state over fire
providers is that you're going to have
to update the state every time and reset
it to that state variable and that's why
we implemented that copy with
function here so because we could take
all the previous
things that we don't want to change and
copy with the new values
okay so we have initialized
now we need to do this whole middle
section and then again we go to the
participant side of things and we could
pretty much copy paste this obviously
we're going to need to update specific
parts
but the essence is very similar
so wherever we see engine
we need to do state dot engine
wherever we see client
i'm going to do
state dot client we actually get some
issues here because this is named the
same thing but we're going to change it
to st instead
and now the last one is the channel
we can change to state.channel
so on join channel success we don't need
to do anything here we're just going to
print out
director
and the uid
so we could just see if they joined here
leave channel
we don't really have to do anything here
and the rest of the event handlers will
handle a little bit later so here to log
in there's no widget necessary
because we're actually past the channel
name and the uid
we could just remove that and actually
the one thing that is definitely hard to
catch here
is we're setting the state dot channel
if you remember i said
i mentioned we reassigned that state
variable every single time if you want
the ui to update
so this doesn't really work for us
what we want to do instead is state
dot copy with
channel
and then pass in this channel that we're
waiting for
so now this will create the channel and
we'll be able to access that
state.channel
whenever we use it so now we got all the
setup for agora and rtc and rtm setup
and we can close this function a little
bit until we need to add those event
handlers
and it won't clutter up too much stuff
let's close this initialize and
and we can even close this leave call
so now we want to test it out and make
sure that we get this
director and the uid printed out so like
i said we're going to do that in the
init state where we try to join the
channel
and in here since we don't really care
about the return of that we're going to
read
our director controller dot notifier
click the join call function and we have
a channel name that is passed into this
widget and we have a uid that's also
passed into this widget
or so i thought i guess it's not passed
in yet so we want that to be passed in
all right we've got it on the home
screen and then director screen now as
well
so this context.read
if we look at the description it reads a
provider without listening to it so this
watch we're listening to all the changes
and we want to update depending on
what's going on here and here we just
read it and we forget about it so we
just call that joint call function let
it do the rest and we don't even have to
worry about it so okay then i think the
director application should be working
now if we run it we should see our
emulator pop out a director with the uid
printout just like that and then we'll
know everything works on this end okay
so we were able to get to this screen we
see that the stored id is six three four
six five seven seven six four
and we joined the director we should see
something very similar
so username will go with tardis
titus here click director
we get to the director screen and
director boom
six three four six five seven seven six
four the same exact uid as you got there
so it seems like everything works we're
able to join the call
now we can move on to the next section
and that's actually bringing on people
into the lobby and into the stage and
managing multiple users within the call
and we're going to do that by going to
the director controller and then this
join call function
so remember i said we're going to add
more events to the event handler we're
going to have an event for user joined
and user offline now in this first
section let's just print out that the
user joins so we can have all the
details in there and here we're just
going to have to implement two functions
so we're going to have add user
to
lobby
and we're going to need their uid
and then when the user jumps offline for
whatever reason we want to remove
user
again we'll need to define which user we
want to remove
now let's close up this join call
function and implement those two
functions
so the first one we're going to have
is the
add user to lobby and remove user
and we see these errors that we had here
go away now we just need to implement
them so these two functions are actually
pretty straightforward we just need to
add a user into our lobby users set so
once again this is since this is a state
notifier we need to reset that state
variable and we'll do that with a copy
with
and we need to update the lobby users
value
we're going to do that by taking
the old lobby users
and i forget what this what this is
called again
so this is called a spread operator you
put these three dots before a list and
you get all the values within that list
added into the previous list and same
thing works with sets so here we're
taking all the lab users putting them in
a list
and then at the end we will add another
lobby user
which will be defined as an agora user
uid we're getting that passed in
we want them to be muted at first
we want their video to be disabled at
first as well
the name we don't have that part sorted
out yet we'll actually instead of naming
it wait we'll name it to do
to dude
and background color
we also don't have it sorted out but
we'll start the blue for now
we'll do that real soon but let's
implement the remove users
and then also allow them to be moved
into active users as well
so the remove user is actually a little
bit more complicated than the add user
to lobby since we need to check in both
the lobby and in the active user state
but it's still not too bad so first
let's create some temporary sets
and then all we have to do is loop
through all of these people in the
active users list and in the lobby users
list
so you see this is a nice for loop that
goes the length of the active users
checks if the element at that user is
equal to the uid which we want to remove
and if so remove it from that list and
once we have that update the state
with our new active and new lobby users
now we're going to switch a little bit
to the ui side of things so we can
actually see this stuff working in
action but before we do that we're going
to set up the base of the next two
functions that we're going to need to
add
so we had add user to lobby remove user
but there's two more functions that we
need
and that's to be able to promote the
user to an active user while they're in
the lobby and to demote that user from
an active user back into the lobby and i
guess before we even go to that maybe it
makes sense to actually implement these
they're not that much more complex than
these other functions so to promote the
user the lab user to an active user you
want the temporary lobby of all the
current lobby users
and then this temp color and temp name
is this name and color that were
assigned right here
they're obviously not initialized but we
want to pass that value on to
the active user as well so a similar
loop we loop through the temporary lobby
we check where in the uid is equal to
the uid that we want to promote
let's save this temporary color that we
have
so from this agora user we're just
copying this these values into a
temporary variable and then removing
that person from the temporary lobby
after we remove it we need to set the
state again so now the active users
will be
the previous active users
plus a new agora user
with uid uid
background color equal to temp color
and their name will be equal to temp
name
okay so we're copying we updated the
active users to have the new active user
but remember we need to also update the
lab users
to use the new
lab users without the specific person in
there and now we could pretty much copy
paste the same exact thing
it's a very similar code for the
demotion process but wherever we see
lobby
want to change to
active
and then wherever we see active we want
to change that to lobby
the only difference here is we want to
make sure they are muted
and that their video is disabled
okay so even that's added in now so the
management of all the users going
between the active users and lab users
is all complete
now let's implement the ui so you can
actually see it in action
so for the ui part we might go a little
bit faster just because the ui i think
matters a little bit less how the actual
back end of it works i think is the most
important part of this course but i
still wanted to cover the ui here so we
have our whole scaffold wrapped in this
consumer which is so if you remember
this we'll keep watching our state for
any changes and we'll be able to update
our ui whenever any of those change so
inside the scaffold we will actually be
doing a custom
scroll view
because we can have a bunch of people
within the call within the lobby within
the active users and wanted to be able
to scroll nicely
and then this will be implemented using
slivers
so the first section will have a sliver
list
a sliver child
list delegate
and here we'll just add a
nice safe area where for now we'll just
put the word director in there so if you
don't know what slivers are slivers are
pretty much little pieces of code that
work well with within the scrollable
view and so the sliver list is very
similar to
just a widget within
the sliver so
like a nice row within a sliver view or
within a custom scroll view so the next
part is we're going to check whether the
users are empty or not
it's going to take the director data
or let's see if there's any active users
and if it's empty we will just display
another sliver list that says this is an
empty stage
but this is where it gets a little bit
more interesting
here we'll add a sliver
grid
so for the sliver grid we'll need a
delegate and a grid delegate so for the
grid delegate we're going to define
something called the sliver grid
delegate with max cross axis extent so
this section pretty much defines how big
each of your children are going to be so
here we define the maximum extent of the
cross axis for each tile we wanted to
take up half of the screen i wanted to
have some spacing in it too
and the way we get half the screen as we
get is we need to get this size object
and we're just going to define it up
here because we'll probably use it
in a different section as well
so we define the size by doing midi
query context dot size and this returns
the size of how many pixels is the size
of our screen pretty much
so we take the pixels of our screen
divided by two that's how much each grid
element is going to have but we also
want to have it give us some spacing of
20 pixels and that will give us the look
that we want then there's a delegate
which is the actual
child so this defines what we want each
child to look like and how many children
there is going to be
so here we will use a sliver
child
builder delegate so in here i just
decided to copy paste to make it a
little bit easier but let me explain it
to you
so this sliver child builder delegate
where we get the context and an index
for which child it is
so total child is going to be the active
users.length so how many active users we
have and then each child will have the
following design
where we have a row
and we expand it and then
create this stage user now the stage
user i'll just paste it in and then
we'll set up the rest of it and show you
what the ui looks like and go through
this in more detail
because i think it's kind of hard to
imagine just with words
okay and then we put a little divider in
between so once again using a sliver
list and here we'll just do a divider
with thickness of three and then some
indents on the side and then literally a
copy paste of this above thing for
active users except the same thing for
lobby users now and again we need to
implement this lab user but i'll just
copy paste and it's the same layout as
the stage user
but i think it'll just be easier to
showcase when you can actually see the
ui as well so i think that's the ui for
the most part i know there's a lot of
pacing here but we're gonna go through
it right now after we start it up so i
could actually showcase you with an
example app and and what each part
actually does
okay so we have username
we'll just call it director
since this username doesn't really
matter channel will go to tatus
click director and we should see this
weird director text at the top
it's there for a reason right now you'll
see it soon but
we could have just added an empty
container there actually let's let's do
that just to make it just to make it a
little bit less cluttered so with an
empty container it's a little bit less
cluttered and we have
the
the stage and the lobby here
now i'll actually need to join from a
different device for the first time if
you remember in the director controller
when we said when we join we have a
color of blue and the name is to do
that's what we get here this is why we
set the colors so we're gonna
let the people input their colors and
have their names appear here but for now
it's to do and the color blue
so this is the design that we have and
there's actually one piece i missed to
make it look a little bit nicer actually
within the scroll view let's add some
padding around this
and we could actually keep it at eight
so now it's going to look a slightly bit
nicer
so back to the lobby user let's see what
we did in order to get this ui
so we use a clip our wreck so this takes
uh the rectangle that we created we
create the blue rectangle and takes off
the a little bit of the border now in
this case we actually check if the video
is disabled before showing our stack of
widgets if it's not disabled will
actually show their view and i realize
this probably isn't necessary anymore
because as a lobby user your video
should always be disabled
so we could simplify this a little bit
so then this clipped rectangle we have a
container that has the color of blue
that we passed in with
so this is the we take the lab user and
at that element we take the background
color value
so the background color value is blue if
for some reason there's some error with
this background color we'll display
black
and if there's no name we display error
name but we take that lab user at the
specific element and we display his name
and this one we have to do so i guess we
could have not added to do or color in
this case we just get black and an error
name and then this is all within the
stack so on top of it we have a little
container
with again a border radius of 10 to fit
into the corner
and that's that's what this is so it's
like a little button that fits into the
corner
we made it a little transparent black
and whenever we press on it we will
promote this user to an active user and
if we set everything up within the
director controller correctly when we
press this button we should be taken
into the stage
the video should come in of me and we
should have a very similar ui on the
stage so let's try it out now
so here we go so for the stage user we
have a very similar ui we'll have the
same rectangle that we had here
except now we actually care about the
surface view that we would have
and then we want to put buttons on top
of that service view
so we'll have different buttons one to
either bring the user back into the
lobby like this
or to turn off their video or to turn
off their audio
and after video is turned off we'll have
a nice video off screen
then this section takes that background
color that we have from the user puts at
the bottom corner
and then takes their name and adds that
here as long as you know their names
available and you notice we have these
buttons over here so i commented some of
the functions out because these aren't
implemented yet but when we click on
these we'll toggle the other users audio
and the other user's video these buttons
have a very similar setup as what we saw
in the lobby user except there's three
of them now
and they also change colors depending on
the state so when the video is disabled
this will be red when the video is
enabled this will be white and same
thing with the mic muted so that's what
the stage user widget looks like
so the next step we're going to do is
actually implement these toggle user
audio and toggle user video functions
so these when we see the word toggle
that's when we're doing it as a director
we're toggling them on and off but
there's one thing to remember
is that the participant user can
actually click these toggle buttons on
their own side
and we need to update these states based
on that as well i'll do that through the
event handler where we'll find there are
some functions to check whether the user
has updated the audio or video
we will be adding four new functions
here
so first one will be
toggle user
audio
we'll need to pass in which index of the
user is
so in the ui we actually know which
active user needs to be toggled so we
can just pass that index directly make
it a little easy on us
and then if we want it muted
we will send a message to mute
and otherwise you want to unmute
send a message to unmute
now you might be asking why are we
sending a message instead of unmuting
them directly so this mute functionality
is actually going to be
us sending a request for the user to
mute themselves actually maybe that
makes it more clear to start with the
update user audio then so this gets a
little bit complicated because again we
need to rewrite the whole state object
here so we're going to do is actually
take the whole agora user
we're going to find the element where
the uid equals the uid we pass in we're
going to set that to a temp variable
and we have a temporary set of active
users
we're going to remove that specific
temporary user
and we'll add that user back in
with whatever mute state that it needs
to be added in with now we just reset
that state
or reassign that state with the new
active users
and that should technically work fine
now there might be a better algorithm to
do this there might be a simpler way a
more efficient way but this works just
fine
now let's copy this function
and change this to update user
video instead
so same logic here we're going to find
that user within the active users list
we're going to create a temporary set
but then instead of copying muted
we're going to copy video disabled
now we need to execute those functions
when an event gets triggered
and the event that we want to get
triggered is remote audio state changed
and for the other one it'll be remote
video state changed
and here we will check
if state is equal to audio
remote
state
decoding
and if we take a look at what this means
it means remote audio stream is decoded
and plays normally
so that means we're unmuted and we
should be playing
and then we can actually just call that
update user audio
with the uid and muted with false
then otherwise
if state is equal to audio remote state
dot stopped
want to update user audio
to
be muted in this case
now very similar thing here
so we need to change this to video
and change this to
video disabled
so you can actually test this out on our
device to see if it updates to the
correct color
all right again the username doesn't
really matter
channel name taris we go to director
nobody here i'll join on my end
here we have a participant
i'll bring this person
into the stage
and there we go i muted and you can see
the red icon if i turn on my camera you
see video off and camera turns off
if i turn it back on everything seems to
be working well
okay so that section was if the user
mutes themselves on their end so we have
it updating accordingly
now this last part is we need to
we need to be in control of them as well
so we have toggle user audio and toggle
user video
we had toggle user audio
almost implemented
yeah
so we need to be sending a message to
mute and unmute them and this is where
agora rtm comes in real handy so we're
going to send them a message they're
going to mute themselves
and then through this function that we
implemented up here update user audio
we'll get their updated state here but
they'll pretty much be muting themselves
so what we want to do here is take the
state
and it's going to be a channel wide
message
so we're going to send a message and the
message is going to be formatted like
this
so yeah rtm channel
from text
now rtm channel rtm message
from text
and if we're already muted that means we
want to unmute
and we want to make sure to give the uid
of who we want to unmute
so our message is going to say unmute
followed by uid
same thing here
except here we are now muting with that
id
now we can copy paste this
and change this to toggle user
video
instead of muted
we'll just say enable
if enable we'll use the word disable
this uid and then if it's already
enabled we will enable it so the next
part of this is we need to accept these
messages and do the correct actions
upon these messages
but in order to not jump around
everywhere
let's add all the other rtm send
messages in here so if you remember back
to this drawing the participant view you
shouldn't be seeing yourself right we
need to be seeing all the people within
the stage
so we need to somehow send
all the users that are within the stage
to the participant and this is going to
be the last type of message that we're
going to be sending so we're going to
send audio mute and unmute messages
we're going to send video enable and
disable messages and we're going to send
active user messages so these are going
to need to be executed every single time
something changes with the user so all
four of these functions will need to
have some sort of active user message
i'll actually create another util here
we'll call it
message.dart now these helpers are going
to be used to make it just slightly
easier for us to work with sending all
the list of active users
so we're going to have a class called
message
and it's going to have
a function inside that returns a string
because our rtm message needs to be a
string
and we're going to call this send active
users
so we need to be passed in a
a set of agora users
now we'll need to be turning this set
into a string value
so our string will start with the
keyword
active users followed by a space
the space is important then we set up a
for loop to go through all the active
users
and let's actually set up our return
to return the user string
and within this for loop we're going to
append
onto the user string
so the user string
plus
active users dot element at
the specific index
we take their uid
turn into a string
and then
add a comma after that
so this is what our messages are going
to look like
it's going to look like
active
users which is the keyword we'll look
for and followed by uid uid uid uid
so okay we're gonna send out this string
but when we receive it we actually need
to parse that specific string and get
that list of users again
so let's create that function here
so you want the list of agora users
parse
active users
and i'll pass in a string of uids
so before this step
we will
look for space within the code
that will tell us that this is active
users and we will send the string of uid
uid uid uid
so this is the type of string that we're
going to retrieve here
so i'll create a list of these strings
and split them where the comma is
and we're here to be turned into aguar
users
so that we can use it within our app
so we'll need to loop through all the
gore users
we'll check if this is an empty string
because you remember we're parsing on
every comma
at the end there will be an empty string
here
with nothing
so i'm going to get to that point want
to continue out of the for loop and keep
keep going
but before we get to that part we want
to
take all the users and we want to create
agora users from that uid and we get
that from the list of strings that we
have
we parse it turn it into an integer and
set it to our uid and finally we're
ready to return the users
all right that was a little bit more
algorithm heavy but hopefully this all
makes sense we're basically working with
string manipulations
now going back to director controller so
we said we need to add it to these four
functions
so when we add the user to lobby we want
to set out send out a message of these
active users so that the participant can
update their own screen
so we take the channel send message our
message is going to be agora rtm
message
from text
i'm going to call that message class we
created
and
say send active users
and the active users we're going to send
as the current state of active users
because we
already just updated that state
right here so we updated the status new
and ready to send out now when we
promote them to active user
we can copy that same thing
there'll be a new user
but on top of that we want to add two
more messages want to unmute that person
and we want to actually enable their
video as well
we don't want to have them come into the
stage and their videos off and
everything that'd be a mess
so now when we're demoting them to a
lobby we want to do the opposite of this
well except for that last line we still
just want to update with the current
state of the active users
but in this case we want to mute that
user and want to disable
their video
and lastly when we remove the user
we'll send them the new active users as
well and we don't have to worry about
muting or immuting them because they're
gone okay we're getting very close to
the finish line here so next part is we
want to retrieve these states with the
participant side of things i want to
address those actions that are those
messages that are being sent over we
want to listen to them and do the
correct
thing so remember these messages we were
sending out are channel wide messages so
we're going to be using this section a
lot so this is where we'll see our
message and which member sent it and all
that stuff
so first thing we need is
to parse for that space that we added
if you remember in all of our message
definitions we have that first
identifying word either enable mute
unmute disable or active users followed
by a space
so we're gonna
split that text into a list of strings
based on where the space is
now we can set up a switch case
statement
we can look at the parts message and
position zero because we know there
should be two positions total
the first specific word and then the
rest of the message
so in the case that we need to mute
we will check
the parse message in position one
we will check if it's equal to
our uid
so we need to set the state of muted to
equal true
since we want to mute this person
and then since that only does it locally
like on our side of the app we want to
also let the engine know that this
person has muted themselves
now this mute local audio stream will
trigger our director controller event
for remote audio stay changed
if it's muted or stopped this will
execute
and then the rest of the logic executes
now you can imagine we'll have something
very similar for the other cases
so we'll have the case of unmute
where this is just false
and this is false
and then we'll have the case of disable
and enable
where this will be video disabled
and this will be
mute
video stream
now the last one is actually becomes
pretty easy for us as well
because of how we set up that parts
active users function
so you get active users as the first
part of that parse message
let's add a break in here so we don't
forget
all we have to do is set
state
and set our current users
to
message
parse active users
uids is still going to be parsed message
at index one
users can't be a setter because it's
final who made a final i didn't make a
final
wasn't supposed to be
okay
so all the messages are accounted for
now one of the last things we need here
is to actually show the ui of all the
users
so toolbar is pretty much done
the main thing we have to do is just
broadcast you
i think i'll just copy paste this in
here because again it's
it's not the most important part of this
application that we're dealing with
and this reminds me we needed one more
thing to add in so this active users
so we want to have this variable called
active user to know if they're on the
main page or not
because we don't want to display all the
buttons we don't want to have them the
ability to mute or change their cameras
if they're not even on the screen
and let's actually change this name to
local user
active
because
we have the active users over there i
don't want to get confused
so we'll update this
i explained that logic in a little bit
but let me update the buttons first so
we have the mute button here
want to check if the local user is
active if he is active then we want to
display that material button
but if he's not
just display an empty size box
then call button we do want because we
wanted them to be able to leave the call
but the video disable button we don't
want again
same situation as above we'll just
create an empty size box and then switch
camera we again don't want this
and if it's not active then we want to
display a sized
box again
all right so there the buttons are
updated now let's go through the view a
little bit so this broadcast view gets
all the render views that we have
and the render views function we have a
list of all the users so we have
the agora user with the uids
we go through that list if the list is
equal to your own uid
then you create an rtc local surface
view
so that means it takes your camera view
and that's what we're going to be using
and we're going to be putting the user's
username at the bottom as well
and then so if we already did a check to
see whether you are in the active users
list so if you are then check if local
active gets set
and that's how we set the local user
active thing
otherwise we'll use the rtc remote
surface view so this means a surface
view or a video view that is not coming
from your own device
and again same thing we'll have the
username at the bottom right
so you get these stacks of different
views
and now we need to set them into a grid
of what we want it to look like
so if it's zero you take up the whole
screen if it's two you take up the top
and bottom and then if you have three or
four you set them into their own view
and if you want or need to add even more
you can with a gore you can add up to 17
and i think that might be increased soon
even on these expanded views just
put this into an expanded row pretty
much so that's that's the ui the core
thing you want to understand here is how
the agora logic works here the uis i'm
not as worried about and with the al
gore ui key you don't even have to worry
about that in the first place it's okay
let's run it let's see if it works
okay so we will first try out the
director
part where we'll try to mute the people
so when we join we'll see this blue to
do again
on my site i see only an end call button
but we'll showcase that here as well and
then we bring the user in here we should
be able to mute them so let's try it out
there it works and i can actually see on
my end we'll swap the rolls around and
then i'll show you there too
but i can show you here if we turn off
the video
it makes the video off and everything is
working well
now let me show you this from a
participant point of view
so if we join us a participant we see
the end call button with nothing else
so this is the lobby we don't see
anybody in the lobby but when we try to
bring the person in
you'll see we have the name director and
we have that little android emulator
and now i won't
see my mouse is here i'll click mute on
the other end
and you see the state updates here to be
muted and i can turn off the video i
mean though we still see it here locally
because we didn't update the ui to do
anything when our video is off
and we're still technically on the stage
we see the state is updated so okay
everything seems to be working well so
last thing we need to do is add some
logic to generate the color and send the
name of the user to the director and
we're going to do that within the
participants join channel success
so this is when you successfully join
the channel on your own end we can
actually remove this users.ad here
because we're not relying on this
anymore the director is sending us all
the information for what users we
actually need to display i actually saw
a little hiccup on
my second device when this first
launched
because i saw the screen pop up for a
second and then go back to nothing
because we added that user here on this
join channel success but then as soon as
we received the message we set that back
to nobody so that was a bug that would
have technically been hard to spot so
let's generate a random color and then
also give the name that we want to pass
so to get a random color
we're just gonna do
random
dot next
double
multiply by that by
all the colors
and turn it into an integer
and to send these we're going to be
using
a local attribute that we can get access
to from the director directly
it's a good way to phrase it so i want
to add or update
local user attributes
this attribute is going to be name and
color
so see these local attributes take in
a list of maps so we need to create key
value pairs for the name and for the
color so the first one is the name and
then let's get the color
color the key will be color
and randomcolor.2string
to string is what we would want to pass
here
so on the director side of things
if you remember when we first joined
right here we just set it to a to do and
colors blue
instead we're going to
get the user attributes
and we do that by
asking the client for
the user attributes
for this specific uid and to access them
we just get the key value pairs we look
for a name
and to set the color we want to
get the integer and then user attributes
color okay
now unless i'm missing something
we should have colors here
so there we go we joined you see we got
a random color we see the name todas
if we leave
join back
we should get another random color i
believe
a darker green
hopefully they're not all going to be
greens
yeah we got a nice orange here
and if we bring them into the call we'll
see the same orange with the name down
here
seems to be working great
nice
so all the core logic with the lobby and
active users and sending rtm and rtc
messages is all done we're getting all
the people within the call and now the
only thing left to do is to actually
stream them out to all the other
platforms and to me this is the most
exciting part so if you remember we had
this model set up called stream but we
never added anything to here let's
change that so first we're going to
create a enum called stream
platform we'll add youtube
twitch
and other
they'll have a class called stream
destination
this will have a stream platform
and a url where we want to stream
so this is a very simple class we just
want the platform and then the url so
this section even though it might seem
like it should be complicated with agora
again it's not too bad so let's close
all these functions just to make our
code a little bit more readable and at
the bottom here we're going to add a
couple more functions actually before
that we need to update our director
model 2 because we're going to need to
store a couple more things here
so first we need a boolean for is live
so know whether we are currently live
streaming or not
and then we will need a list of stream
destinations
so that we know where to stream to
and then we need to update that copy
with function
but again we need defaults for that so
we're going to start with false
and
our current destination start with zero
all right so now that we got that data
in there we can go back to director
controller
and we can work with that now so we'll
have data for whether we are live and
all the destinations we want to stream
to so the first function we're going to
want is start stream second function
will be called update stream so if the
user gets brought into the stage while
the stream is live we want to update
that user we want the ability to end
stream
then a function for publish destination
and we're going to need to import this
enum as well
so add publish destination is when we
click we want to publish to youtube or
twitch we will add that into our
destinations
and then if we add it we need a ability
to remove it so these are actually the
last functions that we're going to need
within our controller one thing we want
to do before diving too deep into that
is whenever there's a change with the
active users we want to check if it is
live
and if so want to
update
that stream
so this is the scenario when you get
promoted to an active user
this is the same scenario when we demo
to the lobby user and then also the same
thing if we remove the user while this
isn't always going to be the case it
doesn't hurt to update the stream just
in case
so now to add published destinations
we want to give the ability for people
to add a published destination while
they're already live so if you're
already streaming on youtube you want to
add it into twitch real quick
you can do that and it should update
so here if we check state dot is live
if we are live we want to take the state
engine and add
publish stream url
so our passed in this url and
transcoding enabled
we'll set it to true now i'll give a
little bit more insights on what that
actually means a little bit later
and then whether it's live or not live
we want to update the state with the new
destination
we'll do that with copy with then
destinations
and very similar to how we did the users
we want to
use the spread operation
get all the destinations and add a new
stream destination
with platform
platform
url url
so to remove a published destination
we got to do something very similar so
check if it's live if it is want to
remove publish stream url
we don't need transcoding
and then we do a little bit of logic
here
where we loop through all the current
destinations
we check if
we check for the location of the current
url that we want to remove
we remove it and then we set the state
with the new locations
and we can return we don't need to loop
through the rest of it
so that's how we add destinations and
that's how we
remove destinations
now we actually have all the data we
need
to finish up the ui we have the complete
director controller with all the pieces
we can finish that up
and then the last thing we're going to
need to do is implement these last three
functions then we can show you the fully
working application
all right so for the ui we have the
little section at the top where we want
to add all our streams and things like
that and actually since this is all
going to be ui stuff we can just launch
this app and see our changes get updated
real time
actually before we get into all that we
want to wrap our custom scroll view and
another widget and this switch is
actually one of the packages that we
installed
called circular menu
so let's take our custom scroll u wrap
it with a widget
we'll call it circular
menu
just like the package wants so items is
required
that's the required field and then
instead of child it should be background
widget so the circular menu puts
basically a little floating menu thing
above
our
whole view so we have the items but we
can also add some things like alignment
we're gonna align it to the bottom right
go ahead and change the toggle button
color to colors
black 87 and might as well give it a
little bit of a shadow just to give it
a little extra spice
now if we log into this director channel
we should see
an error pop up because items cannot be
empty all right i'll add some items so
in here we're going to need to define
circular menu items this first one is
going to be a big end call button so
whenever we want to end that call we
will
call the director notifier leave call
and then pop out of this context so go
back to the old screen
and then the second item we'll have in
here is check whether we are live or not
if we are live
add a button called end stream where we
call the end stream function that we
haven't yet implemented
and if we are not live we will call
start stream
and the colors will be orange for both
of them and this one will be
a video cam icon and then this one will
be a cancel icon and then we also do a
little check here before we start it to
make sure that there's at least one
destination where we want to start the
stream too
if not we'll throw a error called
invalid url
all right so let's try again
and go to the director and we should
hopefully see a nice little button in
the bottom right there we go
now if we click this button you'll see
an end call and a start live stream
so in the call
will take us back to this screen
and go back into the director alright so
that section is done now the next is
this safe area that we just left an
empty container for now so that was on
purpose
we're actually going to turn this into a
row so for this one we're going to use
another package that we added in
called the pop-up menu button
and we're going to use it in conjunction
to this modal bottom sheet as well so
the pop-up menu button
takes in the item builder where we'll
need to return a list of
pop-up menu items
we're going to need to return this list
at the end and before we return them we
need to fill it up with all the
different things we need so this part is
going to be where we're adding the
actual
stream destinations
and everything within here needs to be a
pop-up menu
item and it will have a child and a
value
and the reason we had that enumeration
that we declared is because we want this
value to be to be for youtube now the
child will be a simple list tile and
just like that we have our first pop-up
menu item
then we'll add a little divider in
between
using the pop-up menu
divider
and that's put in the wrong spot there
we go and i'll have a little divider
between the next section where we can
copy paste the same thing
call this twitch
make the string platform twitch
and then copy this a third time to add
an other field
all right so we have our pop-up menu
defined here but there's a couple more
things we need to add in
so the icon
i'm going to use this similar
icons.add
and there's some functions you can
implement like on cancelled where all
we'll do is just print
you have cancelled
menu
then we have on selected so if you
actually choose something
and this is where this value comes in
very handy
we can create a switch case statement
for this value
if it's a stream
platform
dot youtube
we will do one thing
if it's
if it's twitch
we will do something separate
and then lastly we will have a shape
of rounded
rectangle
border
with border radius of border
radius circular
of 16.
all right there we go
so next big thing is when we actually
picked one we want to have a little
bottom sheet pop out so for youtube we
will have a function called show
youtube
bottom
sheet
where we'll need to pass the context and
the director notifier
because we'll need to access that
function to add the publish destination
all right so let's create this function
we will do it up here and before we
implement this let's go over how to
actually stream something to youtube
so when i go to youtube you're ready to
go live you click this go live button
and you'll have this stream key and
you'll have a stream url and those are
two things you're going to need to do an
rtmp push to youtube so on twitch you
get a stream key as well but but you can
go to stream.twitch.tv
ingests and it tell you what the actual
url you need so you take this url at the
beginning and then add your stream key
at the end and using those two values
you can actually rtmp push your stream
to both of the platforms so i need to
input that here
create text editing controller
with the stream url then copy that and
have a stream key
and for this return we actually want it
to be we want to return the bottom sheet
here
now we get that from
show
modal bottom sheet so we have the
context
and within the builder
we actually need to build out this form
and nothing too complicated about this
one
we just basically fill out a column with
all the things that we want to add so
first add a little text then some space
between the next thing
then a text field for our stream url a
text field for our stream key
and then a nice button at the bottom
that
says add and this goes to our director
notifier and does the add publish
destination we add a youtube destination
we take the stream url add a slash
and add the stream key to the end
and that's our url for the stream
destination so this guide i was reading
earlier had a different way to set up
the twitch stream so they said
do rtmp slash slash twitch ingest server
slash app slash stream key
and the way i found this twitch interest
server was
going through obs but i have a feeling
this would work just fine so maybe maybe
you want to make this your url and make
it more clear to your users how to how
this all works but yeah the main point
of this is that your app actually goes
gets the twitch so try these out and uh
maybe this is actually simpler to use
just guide people to this website and
then they could find it plus had a very
similar function for twitch so the way i
had it was using this old method with
rtmp slash slash app and then stream key
again just going to the direct ingest
server might be easier
so feel free to update this as necessary
okay those two are implemented now we
could
show
twitch bottom sheet
we have context and director notifier
all there
now when we click on this we should see
these options pop up so all right we
have this first pop-up menu button
and right after that pop-up menu button
we're going to loop through
all of the destinations and return some
more pop-up menu buttons
with the actual
streams
so remember the item builder needs to be
a list of things even though this is
just one thing the child will be
stream button
with the director data and
destination for that specific one we'll
define what this stream button is in a
second and then the same three functions
we have the on canceled we have
cancelled the menu on selected instead
of adding a published destination here
we will be removing a published
destination
with that specific url again
and then a very similar border
so last part of the ui we want to add
this stream button so this will return a
widget of stream button
and we're going to pass it a stream
destination
we can set up a nice switch statement
depending on the platform
if it's youtube we want to return a
container
with the child
text that says
youtube
style it to be white
give it a little bit of decoration
and then since it's youtube we want to
make it red
give it a little bit of padding
a little bit of margin
and there we go so the youtube ones
defined we'll have a very similar thing
for twitch instead of right here we'll
have purple instead of youtube we will
have twitch
and the rest should be the same
and then lastly
we have the other we'll make this color
black
change the switch to
other
okay
so finally the ui should be done
let's run it so again we have this
director
channel named tatis let's join it
and we'll see this nice plus icon at the
top
if we click this we'll see a bunch of
options youtube twitch other let's click
youtube
we'll see this pop up
stream url
let's just put in for now youtube.com
just as a test stream key
whatever
oh and we actually had some sort of
overflow there
but anyways add that in and we should
see youtube
we can click on youtube to remove it
now let's figure out what this is all
about so we need to add this is scroll
controlled and set this to true for our
bottom sheets and then we won't have
that overflow problem
and we are we did on this one all right
so now in this case we go to youtube
no overflow
might want to add some some sort of
checks here
but we just want to make sure it all
looks nice first
go to twitch
add in there we have multiple things
and we can remove them and add them as
necessary
so ui is all there so now the very very
last thing is we actually need to push
this stream to our streaming platforms
and we actually have this all set up so
we have end stream and we have start
stream all ready and set up to go
and we only have three functions to
implement there there's up update stream
and stream and start stream update
stream you remember we call this
whenever the active users changed
so that's already handled so this is
also called whenever we need so last
thing is just just implement them
let's start with the end stream because
it's the easiest one so we loop through
all the destinations
and remember to add a published
destination we do this add publish
stream url to remove do you remove
published stream url so all we really
need to do is loop through and remove
every single publish stream url just
like that and then we set the state to
state copy with
is live
false and that's how you end the stream
now for the start stream
we need to create a list of transcoding
users
so if the active user is empty we should
probably do some sort of error checking
but in this case we're gonna pretend we
don't like error checking and move to
state
active users length equals one
so to best showcase what we need to do
with this transcoding
is to look at this this drawn out image
so transcoding means we need to define
the width and the height of each
user and where their location is within
that block so here when we only have one
we have a user that's 1920x1080
and their
index is 0 0. for this one we have
two users each user will have the
resolution of 960 by 1080
and this one will start at zero zero but
this one will start at
960 and 0
and then so on for we're going to do it
up to 8 users by the way if you prefer
reading through a blog this will also be
in the description so back to the back
to the code so this is what that looks
like so like i said if we only have one
user the starting index will be zero
zero width will be 1920 by 1080.
if we have two users
first one will start at zero zero 960 by
1080 the second will start at 960 comma
zero 960 by 1080 and so on and so forth
up to eight users now then there's this
live transcoding variable we need where
we pass and pass in those transcoding
users that we just defined and set the
total stream height and width to
1920x1080
then on the engine we set
live transcoding with the transcoding
that we just declared
that means we are now live with the
transcoding with these configurations
and then
similar thing as we did for
the end stream
we want to do for the start stream where
we go through every destination
and i want to add publish stream url and
the second variable is whether
transcoding is enabled and it is so we
set that to true
and then is live also to true now last
one update stream so for updating we're
not really changing whether we're live
or not we're not changing or adding any
published stream urls those are done
here right when we do the add or remove
so all we need to do is update the
transcoding whenever the users get added
so copy paste all this paste on the
update stream
and that is it that is the last line of
code for the fully functioning streamer
application
that allows you to
stream with multiple people that you
have control over and allows you to
string to multiple platforms at the same
time
now i understand that some of this might
have been a little bit complex but this
is a complex application complex use
case but i'm hoping that a lot of you
after looking at the proper resources
were able to follow along and see how
agora actually made this a lot easier
than it would be to make from scratch i
honestly don't know where i would even
start trying to implement this without
agora
so let's see this final product in
action
we're gonna run this app and i have a
youtube account that's not the official
youtube account and the nice thing about
youtube is it lets you see your stream
here before actually going live unlike
twitch it makes you go live instantly
i found this out from experience but
we'll be able to run and stream our
stream to here and we'll see all the
changes update it might not be as smooth
here because i'm running an emulator on
a stream and then we'll be using two
other devices to stream into the actual
streamer app as well so this user will
be the director so you could see this
all in action we'll use a channel named
tatis
i'll join as director now we can assign
the youtube stuff right away you can
paste that in here and then copy paste
the stream key in here as well now for
this one
we might want to hide it in this case
espec if you're live streaming this app
you don't want people to see this of
course
but for now we don't really mind i'll
just change my stream key right after
this so you won't be able to use it so
we have added a destination now let's
also run
the same application
the ipad that i have connected and let's
open up a new instance of the terminal
and run a third instance on the iphone
that was available here too all right so
the first device is there
we'll call this username taris and we'll
see it show up here and if you guys are
part of the flutter community and you
know me you probably know my good friend
robert that's also on youtube we'll
pretend like he's the other person in
here
so there we go so let's say we bring
this user in and what i'll do is mute
them right away so the two devices don't
start echoing with each other
all right we should be ready to push
this stream live we click this button
it'll start live stream and we see we
have a connection here
so one thing to remember this whole app
everything we see here is running on
agora so this will probably be
relatively fast
but when it starts going out to youtube
and there we go we finally see it when
it starts going out to youtube it's
going to the cdn using rtmp so it'll
have a little bit of a delay
so now i can bring this other user in
and let's mute them here as well
and you can see it pop up here too
so our apps fully working we're going to
bring them in we could take them out now
and it'll update just like it should and
there you go you see this layout updates
just how it's supposed to as well
now you can add twitch and all these
other streams and stream to all of them
and if you want to enable the stream
right away to both of them whenever you
start streaming from the app click this
auto start and then the twitch one will
automatically start and then youtube
will automatically start so there we go
that's the app i like to call streamer
now if you'd like to learn more about
flutter development or just overall
developer entertainment come subscribe
to my youtube channel at tatuspetro
if you're interested to learn more about
agora and how all this video sdk and
this real-time engagement works go
subscribe to their channel at agora and
overall i really appreciate you watching
until the end of this video this is
definitely the longest video i've ever
made and probably the most complex
project that i've tried to explain with
the video i'm hoping most of you were
able to keep up with it if you have any
questions make sure to put them in the
comments so i'll try to answer them as
much as i can and lastly i'd like to
thank free code camp for giving me this
opportunity and hopefully i'll see you
around here some more